vous êtes dans un dans un centre de
réement
5R l'écran à soleil comme dans la
plupart des des c con dans le monde qui
sont accélérés à des très grandes
vitesses et a des vitesses qui sont
relativement proche de la vitesse de la
lumière il y a une propriété de ces
faisceaux d'électron qui circulent à
grande vitesse c'est que si on les
perturbe par un champ magnétique par
exemple ils vont émettre une lumière
extrêmement intense d'un grand domaine
spectral qui couvre les rayons X
jusqu'au très grande longueur d'onde
l'infrarouge étant un des cas où les
ondes millimétriques étant également
faisant partie de ces lumières qui sont
émises le synchrotron accueille des
lignes de lumière donc une ligne de
lumière c'est un laboratoire qui va
exploiter cette lumière dans une gamme
d'énergie ou de fréquence qui est
particulière à un objet scientifique ou
un but scientifique une analyse une
diffraction des rayons X du rayonnement
visible du rayonnement ultraviolet ou du
rayonnement qui n'est pas visible
infrarouge
la puissance des faisceaux la précision
des faisceaux que nous avons ici nous
permet d'avoir des détails et des
analyses beaucoup beaucoup plus précises
qu'on peut avoir à l'hôpital par exemple
en tomographie on aura des contrastes
qui sont 10 à 100 fois
meilleur je suis le responsable de de
cette ligne de lumière qui s'appelle
proxima 1 au soleil qui est un ligne de
lumière qui est dédié à étudier les
structures des molécules biologiques en
forme cristallin dans le cas de malgne
proxima 1 ça ramasse les rayons X qui
sort du crotron on les focalise avec des
éléments des miroirs on choisit
l'énergie de nos rayons X et on les
amène vers un échantillon qui est
l'échantillon qu'on essaie
d'étudier il y a une une émergence
de technologie qui permettent des avancé
donc on est tous dans la recherche de
l'avancée scientifique qui est la plus
probante à soleil par exemple nous avons
deux équipes bien sûr les équipes de
chercheurs sont là pour exploiter la
lumière nous avons aussi une équipe de
de chercheurs de physiciens de des
accélérateurs qui tous les jours émett
des idées nouvelles pour faire des
faisceaux d'électrons des des des des
arrangements de système Mag qui vont
nous permettre d'obtenir des lumières
beaucoup puissantes beaucoup plus
petites et nous derrière pouvoir
l'exploiter pour aller plus
loin